hey Justin ready to go see San Andreas
oh man um I forgot
I actually made plans with Quinta to see
San Andreas she loves the rock uh yeah
that's cool I mean we all love the rock
yeah hey but uh rain check though
I'll watch the end with you okay all
right have fun
hey Justin ready to go play some
basketball ah sorry man I promised
Quinta I'd play racquetball with her
vinta oh okay cool you could come if you
want
it's okay you know I don't like rackets
rain check then yeah I'll see you later
cool I hope you have a bad ankle injury
what was that I said have a great time
all right
hey bye hey yo chef curry you ready for
smoked salmon Saturday I'm sorry Zach
I'm actually doing sirloin souffle
Saturday's with Quinta sirloin souffle
like a meat in a pastry she's a great
cook sounds like it cool rain check
yeah it's Rachel all right I hope you
burn your meat wait one I hope you meet
her family cool man yeah kukuku
all right Jesse ready for Hawaii oh man
I'm sorry I completely forgot
I made plans to go the Caribbean with
Quinta Justin we already have tickets I
know can you like sell them on
Craigslist or something
I don't think that's how it works your
name is on the ticket just find another
Justin tan they're tons I don't want
another Justin ten
I want this Justin 10 how about we hang
I want to get back
all right you actually promised this
time I promise I'll see you later I hope
she gets bit by a shark wait why I said
she's a lucky and lovely girl thanks but
I hope she gets bit by a shark